and it was like this tidal wave
realization of what in the hell am I
doing here I'm in pain from the top of
my head to the tips of my toes I gotta
pop pills just to sit in this chair and
this coach behind me if I left right now
he'd plug somebody else into my spot it
wouldn't matter to him at all so there's
always thought of like when am I going
to be done when is this over when am I
going to be done putting myself through
this thing so that day had come for me
so there was this relief of being done
but pretty quickly that descended into
who am I what am I going to do with
myself what's my purpose somewhere
between the end of 2015 and fall of
2016. I was at complete Rock Bottom all
of the Escape valves had stopped working
the two hours in the gym the smoking
tons of weed the bottles of wine the
porn all this stuff it just wasn't
working anymore and I was confronted
with the reality of my life